so I want to break away from the idea
that America is suffering from
polarization
we're not a polarized country at all
we're a country with one fairly normal
political party
and one highly abnormal entity why don't
we want to call it a political party
anymore
now why is that it's asymmetric
polarization okay all right asymmetric
Warfare asymmetric polarization now why
did that happen we can talk about all
day long about people who were left out
people left behind the roots of populism
blah blah blah
I blame the people who actually did it
who's the Republican Party
who back in the 1990s decided they were
going to create a politics of Rage
that was how they were going to win
rage well the two go together in this
case okay sure
hatred hatred but organized hatred which
they thought that they could ride to
Victory every four years
they would Rouse up the the half
contempt for these people either way
they don't they don't really like them
they just use them
so for a decade and a half of getting
onto two decades they did this they
roused everybody up knowing they were
going to sell them out they were never
going to get rid of you know abortion
rights right away that was never going
to happen
they continued and they continued and
they thought they could ride it
but if you ride the back of the tiger
you end up inside and that's exactly
what happened to them exactly what
happened to them
and and and the only one who figured
this out the great political genius to
figure this out what's
a failed New York businessman named
Trump who understood what about what had
been happening but I blame
a whole succession of Republicans who
now we all like very much right they're
never trumpers they're all our buddies
they were the ones
so there's an historical thing I I
believe that you can explain politics
best
by explaining politics rather than
trying to find all of the social Roots
yes they're there but somebody's doing
it and I think that if we look at all of
these places by the way we'll find some
a similar kind of dynamic I disagree
absolutely
so so I um and I know I've been called
in to talk about education but you just
you just hit all the wrong buttons I
what what I see in the U.S is not
um one side of bad people who just got
real bad
um what I see is that the thing
um that
goes by liberalism
um that the Democratic party has stood
for in the past has been under a long
State a long stage of Decay
um I come from the bay area in
California very very Progressive very
very Democrat deep blue
um there are literally hundreds of
thousands of homeless people in Cali no
no it's not because of the Republicans
went in there and made them all homeless
no no no yeah yeah so so what you what
you have is you have the rise of
globalization you have the rise of
global capitalism and you have this
class of people who mouth Progressive
words
but they um they fight for the the most
powerful and the wealthiest people when
the chips are down I don't agree with I
I'm not a fan of trump I think he's
despicable but I think you have to look
at
um where that came from what they're
responding to what they see when they
look at our country and it's not somehow
that they see like troglodyte sort of
you know blurry things what they see is
a country which no longer cares about
their well-being which no longer
respects their point of view which no
longer cares about their education which
no longer has any interest in their
flourishing and only wants to see them
suffer that's what I think they say I
agree with 95 of what you just said 95
percent
95 especially with the progressives
there that's not my side
the people who are in San Francisco you
know what's his name Boudin
these are not that's a very minor figure
it's Jeff Bezos
Bill Gates these are the people Biden
got this through that big piece of
legislation a month ago how did he do it
because Bill Gates got interested in it
now people talk about the Russian
oligarchs all true all true however
however
it is not that these are troglodytes
these people are being exploited
they're being used they're being duped
but they're being used by people who
really are evil we will keep
experiencing this crisis of democracy
because this crisis is basically an
expression of panic
it's all about Panic on the part of
people who think that either something
is being taken away from them now or
something has been taken away from them
a long time ago and when people talk
about pluralism it's very important to
understand and you know America we pride
ourselves that pluralism is our public
philosophy India Prides itself on this
and so on in fact it's murderously hard
to get people in a society to live with
difference it's murders I mean
murderously literally murderously hard
and will so in Europe for example I
think there were only two choices open
to Europe the recognition of
multi-ethnicity or fascism I don't see
any other choice
and I think that until we deal with
these problems with this reality then
we're going to experience this crisis
over and over and over again
I totally agree with you we have to
understand that democracy isn't you know
it's a very complex regime and it's not
a natural political regime because
freedom is very complex you have
economic freedom political Freedom
social Freedom Etc and you and and you
have oppositions between all these
category of Freedom you have to to try
to reconcile all this and because in
fact
you you are not uh
you you you you you don't bone as a
citizen of a democracy it's an education
an education to responsibility and
education to respect of the of the of
the others and that's why in fact we
have to understand that there is a
democracy can't be quiet and democracy
is not permanent it's always contested
it's always fragile if you look the
first democracy since it was just 60
years between it was
461 and for 404
before Christ and since the the senior
democracy died of his its defeat against
Sparta but in fact the real cause of the
defeat against Sparta was the fact that
the theoc democracy broke down and that
it was the the populist of this time uh
who who went uh who went to power so we
have to understand and that's why
that it's true that democracy are
peaceful regimes but Freedom will always
be a fight